after spending almost three years
fighting to retake New York and finding
the source of the dollar flu we've now
been presented with the next stage of
the franchise the division to here we're
takin into Washington DC but were we
actually successful in taking back New
York City
[Music]
so let's assist the current situation in
New York hospital infections are still
running rampant around the city the
quarantine zone or ducts and walls are
still up and the big bad villain of the
story
Aaron kina is still missing and he still
has Vitali turning Co and Gordon Amherst
notes and equipment but before we label
this mission is incomplete we need to
consider the role of the division agents
and why they were activated in the first
place strategic homeland division agents
are activated when all other forms of
public protection have failed following
the completion of the mission and
averting the crisis the division agents
are deactivated and returned to the
daily lives so when the agents have
brought the situation to a state where
local authorities are able to take back
control
they are deactivated keeping this in
mind we could revisit the previous
statements although still quite active
within New York City the hostile
factions for the most part are
leaderless Joe Farah from the cleaners
Lara Barret from the Rikers and Bliss
from the LMB have all been taken care of
in an addition the numbers are severely
weakened although it's clear that the
factions are willing to follow new
leaders that have stepped up within none
of them being able to fill the shoes of
the previous commanders they were
holding New York City for ransom the JTF
are now the dominant faction within the
city and are now in a much better
position to put an end to the remaining
clusters of writers cleaners and L&B
quarantine zone was set up to contain
the sick while working on a cure for the
virus but it didn't take long for things
to go horribly wrong it quickly became a
no-man's land being run by the growing
hostile presence within to see the
quarantine walls come down would have
been quite the symbolic into the fight
for regaining control of the city
however it's only been seven months
since the events on Black Friday
although the hostile factions are being
brought under control and Erin keener
and his rogue agents have left the area
there is still the original problem to
deal with
the sick thanks to dr. candle there is a
vaccine or cure in development but it
will take time to find and treat all of
the remaining people in the dark zone
this was also delayed because of the
unknown activities going on behind these
walls but thanks to the second wave the
JTF are now fully aware and more
prepared Erin keener has gone in his
final recordings found on the West Side
pier he states that he's long gone from
the city and he has no good reason to
return he has all of Gordon Amherst
notes and equipment and he has the
Russian scientist Vitaly training Co
other than wanting to weaponize the
virus in some way we aren't overly sure
of his plans at the stage but has since
been confirmed that we'll be seeing him
in Washington DC so with kina gone the
hostile factions being brought under
control and a cure found it's fairly
safe to say that the divisions job in
New York is done they're likely to stay
on for a little while as more of a
support role for the JTF but in time
we'll be deactivated returning to the
normal lives
the story around the division one was
based around the release of the smallpox
virus and the finding of a cure while
also taking back New York City the
events of the division to take place in
the summer of Washington DC seven months
after the initial outbreak of the dollar
flu
although the virus is still present a
cure has been developed and the
objective for the Washington's division
agents is more based around the events
after society has fallen apart during
the initial phase of the crisis
important personnel such as the
president Secretary of Defense and the
Joint Chiefs of Staff were evacuated the
first attacks after the outbreak were on
the Pentagon the National Mall and
various landmarks following this there
were riots and the city security forces
were hit hard forcing them to evacuate
the capital as well supply lines were
cut off and after a few days survivors
were forced to band together into
communities organizing themselves taking
up arms and trying to rebuild what's
left rather than just rolling over and
accepting their fate at the same time
other groups started to form but these
groups were less about survival and more
about taking advantage of the situation
using power and aggression to raid these
communities for supply and control one
of these groups is the true sons led by
former jtf officer Antwon Ridgeway this
group was formed when Ridgeway started
losing faith in the JTF stability to
save Washington DC as a strong believer
in the need for authority and discipline
he decided to take matters into his own
hands while in the JTF
Ridgeway deployed his men around the
quarantine on Roosevelt Island blocking
all supplies and allowing the sick to
starve to death as in his eyes the sick
rule really did his priority was
ensuring the well-being of his men
eventually the commander of the JTF
found out and had him imprisoned but it
didn't take long for men loyal tongue to
break him free he didn't see what he was
doing is wrong he believed that he was
the only one with the realistic and
viable solution to the situation and the
betrayal of his fellow JTF officers only
fit as distrust enraged towards the JTF
and the government he captured the
officers they had him arrested and had
them executed
and this is where the division comes in
directive 51 was activated and alongside
the civilian militia they launched a
joint operation to take back the Capitol
the division in Washington DC is going
to be a lot more focused on the
survivors and how they've been changing
and organizing themselves over the last
seven months
so rather than blowing them up with
barrels and shooting their dogs
assisting them and working alongside
them is going to be integral to the
success of the mission anyone who's
watched any of my videos up until now
will know that I couldn't just leave it
here after reading through everything I
could get my hands on regarding the
continuation of the story into
Washington DC they were a number of red
flags that popped up in New York City
the virus was first released on Black
Friday on December 2nd the virus was
acknowledged as an outbreak on December
3rd the joint task force was created
skipping a number of key dates directive
51 was activated on the 18th of December
the division two trailers state that we
the division agents who have been in the
field for seven months are the last hope
to stop the fall of society after the
pandemic collapse so it's fairly safe to
assume that the agents in Washington
were activated at the same time as the
first wave agents of New York City but
where were they for the last seven
months perhaps in another city but if
this was the case why doesn't Washington
DC the most heavily protected city on
earth have their own sleeper agents with
it well maybe they did and they were
sent to other cities to assist but the
still doesn't make sense as to why it
will be left for so long before they
were sent back to the capital especially
when it was stated so many times that if
Washington DC is lost then the nation
Falls
sure it sounds like the JTF were doing a
better job in Washington DC at least a
stat was but being that this is the
capital would support not have been sent
back earlier especially after the events
of New York City yes I know I'm starting
to sound like Rick of Alessi right now
maybe I am Rick the lessee put in place
by Ubisoft to help build hype towards
the next installment of the franchise
[Music]
now I'm terrible Beck since our our no I
struggle enough already with attempting
to make sense with my Kiwi accent but
what I think has happened is the
division agents in Washington DC were
activated on the 18th of December but
some way down the line went quiet and
disappeared I think it's entirely
possible that the man himself
Aaron key no more agents close to him
have spread the word and turned the
agents over to a side killing anyone who
refused kina went missing from New York
long before we found the recordings and
evidence that he intended us to see he
could've been in the capital for months
now the new agent Center in Washington
DC to restore order have come across
from another city close by and have
little to no idea of the events that
happened in New York City I think that
this new squad of division agents
injuring Washington DC will be finding
themselves coming head to head with kina
and his new group of first way of
division agents
obviously this is me speculating based
on the very small amount of information
that we have so far and when the game
actually releases it could go in a much
different direction but given what we
have so far I think this is a completely
plausible part that the story could take
or am I just getting a little bit
excited and ahead of myself let me know
what are your thoughts
thank you to my patrons who continue to
support me regardless of what direction
I tend to take these videos especially
Rick's and Deveraux it really is amazing
to see how many people enjoy the content
I put together it continues to blow my
mind every day thanks again everyone and
I'll see you in the next video Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you